hi in this video tutorial I will be
talking about Keller elimination so
Keller illumination is even illumination
of our specimen so killer illumination
ensures that the light which is coming
from the light source is bathing our
specimen with parallel beam of light and
due to that our specimen is equally
lighted at every places this ensures the
image quality if color illumination is
not achieved then the image quality of
our microscope could be bad and due to
color elimination our not only our image
is enhanced but also the particular
image of the filament of the light bulb
used to eliminate the specimen is not
found in our image I repeat if Kohler
illumination is not achieved then what
happens the image of the light bulb
filament that is used for illumination
could be found in could be focused into
the specimen plane that is why we could
get a image of that particular filament
by Kohler illumination we ensure that we
don't get that kind of any optical
artifact and we get even illumination of
our specimen let's get into details of
color illumination and let's see how
adjustments are done to achieve color
elimination before learning color
elimination we have to understand two
parts of the microscope so one part is
our fill diaphragm just look at the
light path of the microscope and feel
diaphragm is just above the light source
of the microscope if we increase or
decrease the field Ephraim then the
amount of light that would illuminate
the specimen decrease or increase
accordingly an aperture diaphragm is
just above the condenser lens if we also
increase or do
increase the width of the aperture
diaphragm then also the light
illuminating the specimen would be
different now let's get back into our
microscope alignment let's choose our
specimen let's say we choose our
graafian follicle when we choose the
specimen now you can see there is no a
specimen or no nothing is shown in this
particular field of view and it's almost
black why is that because the microscope
alignment is not properly adjusted and
that is why we are seeing this
particular type of field of view black
field of view in order to achieve the
killer elimination first what we have to
do is we have to find focus our specimen
before fine focusing the specimen we
should adjust the condenser in the X and
y-axis we should adjust the condenser
and now you can see we can see some
portion of our specimen but it still
blur so what we can do we can change our
fine focus of the objective and we can
bring our specimen into focus now you
can see our specimen is in focus when we
change the fine focus of the objective
lens then what we would do we would
change the condenser height and until we
get a sharp and crisp edge of this
particular def image of the diaphragm so
these black image whatever you see our
side of this particular specimen is
actually the image of the field I from
so these black theme that you can see is
actually the image of the field
diaphragm so in our second step of the
killer elimination we did adjust the
height of our condenser lens so that the
image of our field diaphragm is focused
on to the
onto the plane of our specimen then what
we would do we would align the condenser
by adjusting it laterally and bring this
a thing at the center of our field of
view as you can see it's almost in the
center of the work field of view after
that what we would do we would open our
field diaphragm just beyond our field of
view so let's open our field diaphragm
when we open the field diaphragm you can
see more and more light is in coming and
we open the filter from just beyond our
field of view and now you can see our
specimen and it's also focused and the
last step would be to increase or
decrease the condenser aperture to
manipulate the light that would
illuminate our specimen the intensity of
the light that illuminate our special so
as we increase the condenser aperture
more and more light is illuminating the
specimen and
after that what we can do we can align
the filament because our Philip filament
is already d focused what we can do we
can focus our filament and increase its
light intensity to get better
illumination now you can see we are
getting up better illumination and this
is how we can achieve the killer
illumination let's try it with another
specimen let's say our fonts poor so
here you can see or let's try with it
with a biotin crystal so you can see
these are the biotin crystals first we
have to do we have to adjust the fine
focus of our objective lens we adjusted
the fine focus and we focus the specimen
there and then what we would do you
change the condenser height and we would
close the field diaphragm first would
close the field diaphragm as far as
possible and but these ages are blurry
stink because the image of the field
diaphragm is not yet on the specimen
plane that is why what we would do would
change the condenser height until the
edges are sharp and crisp when the edges
are sharp and creased that means the
field diaphragm image is on our specimen
plane now we would adjust the condenser
laterally in x and y direction and put
it in such a way that it is just in the
center of the particular alignment so
almost in the center and after that what
we would do we would open the field
diaphragms just beyond our field of view
so we opened our thule diaphragm just
beyond our fluid of you then what we
would do we would change the increase or
decrease the condenser aperture so with
decreasing the condenser aperture you
can see the contrast and resolution is
increasing but the brightness of the
image is
decreasing and we can also increase the
condenser aperture and it is actually
illuminating so let us keep it in a way
such that there is a sufficient amount
of light eliminate our specimen and we
can also align the filament and keep
that thing in focus we can also rotate
the filament and we can increase or
decrease the intensity and accordingly
our image would be done I hope this
video helped you I hope you enjoyed this
video if you liked my video you made a
quick thumbs up and don't forget to
subscribe thank you